en je pense que beaucoup sont venus pour
voter mais au vu de la situation sociale
actuelle nous pourrions voir moindre
enthousiasme par rapport aux années
précédentes
j'espère que cela sera compensé nous ne
pouvons pas laisser notre destin entre
les mains des étrangers et les laisser
décider pour nous et créer des
conditions qui seront absolument néfaste
pour nous nous devons changer la
situation de notre pays
en coopérant les ans avec les autres
objectifs de la présidentielle montrer à
l'occident un sentiment d'unité une
carte à jouer dans un contexte de
négociations sur le nucléaire et
notamment de sanctions économiques
américaines mettant à mal le quotidien
des iraniens grâce à la participation du
peuple
le pays est le système de gouvernement
islamique gagneront deux grands points
sur la scène internationale mais ceux
qui en bénéficient en premier sont les
gens eux mêmes
allez-y choisissez et voter
côté candidats quatre hommes mais des
regards portait particulièrement sur
deux le premier abdel nasser et matis
ancien gouverneur de la banque centrale
d'iran est qualifié de réformateurs
le deuxième celui considéré comme
l'archivage vori l'ultraconservateur
ebrahim raïssi âgé de 60 ans chef de
l'autorité judiciaire fonctions
attribuées par l'ayatollah khamenei en
[Musique]
après deux mandats le président hassan
rohani est donc sur le point de laisser
sa place en 2010 est le candidat
qualifié de modéré avait été réélu dès
le premier tour avec un taux de
participation de plus de 70%
un tour qui sera difficile à réitérer en
temps de crise économique et sanitaire
le pouvoir n'a pas hésité pourtant
allongé l'ouverture des bureaux de vote
jusqu'à minuit avec une possible
extension jusqu'à 2 heures samedi matin
et une élection présidentielle alors que
les négociations autour de l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien sont toujours en
cours elle nous en avons parlé tout à
l'heure avec notre invité l'avocat
franco et radiant kourosh cham louf sans
droits ni n'avait pas beaucoup de marge
de manoeuvre
alors que monsieur raïssi aura pourra
faire ce qu'il veut et il pourra
négocier évidemment il va pas négocier
sur les armes brandies et balistiques
mais il va pouvoir négocier avec une
position forte avec un parlement qui lui
est acquis et commencer c'est le guide
suprême qui qui montre dans un cadre
légal
les les dote pour tout ce qui est des
affaires étrangères salue guide suprême
et raïssi suis ce que dit le guide
suprême et il va signer un accord et cet
accord va libérer normalement de l'iran
est ce que quand tu es cet accord sera
signé on sait pas la seule question qui
est important c est ce que raïs y est
les iraniens pourront faire confiance à
la parole américaine puisque dans quatre
ans il y aura un nouveau président et si
c'est un président républicain il pourra
ressortir de là donc c'est la seule
question qui suspend du week end
élections également en arménie à deux
jours des législatives anticipées les
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées aujourd'hui à erevan en
soutien au candidat de l'opposition
robert kotcharian est le premier
ministre sortant nikola chignon est le
grand favori du scrutin malgré une forte
baisse à de popularité ces derniers mois
valentin carpentier
[Musique]
une dernière prise de parole avant un
vote charnière ce jeudi nikol pashinian
a effectué son dernier rassemblement
électoral dans la capitale erevan
une dernière prise de parole pour
convaincre les derniers électeurs encore
réticents le moment de vérité est arrivé
ces élections représentent une occasion
unique pour les citoyens de la
république d'arménie de s'exprimer
favori du scrutin
le premier ministre sortant vit pourtant
des mois compliqués arrivé au pouvoir en
2018 avec la promesse de mettre fin à la
corruption
nikol pashinian voit sa popularité
chuter depuis l'automne 2020 et le
cessez-le-feu dans le conflit entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan au haut
karabagh après six semaines
d'affrontements ayant coûté la vie à six
mille personnes
erevan avait été contraint de déposer
les armes et de cdd territoire depuis
une vague de protestation a contraint le
chef du gouvernement à la démission dans
l'espoir de rebondir avec ces
législatives anticipées
face à lui robert kotcharian président
du pays de 1998 à 2008
il est le principal concurrent de nikol
pashinian est lui aussi se veut confiant
nous ne faisons pas de violence verbale
nous ne dénigrons pas nos concurrents
nous avons mené une campagne comme nous
avions coutume d'emmener dans une
arménie civilisé avant l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'un populiste nous sommes
plutôt satisfait de la tournure des
événements notre popularité augmente et
nous espérons l'emporter au premier tour
selon les derniers sondage les partis de
nikol pashinian et de robert kotcharian
sont au coude à coude avec près d'un
quart des suffrages chacun
bien loin des 70 % obtenus par le
premier ministre sortant en 2018
quant au vainqueur son objectif premier
sera de remettre sur pied un pays
gravement touchés par le conflit de
l'automne dernier et la pandémie de kobe
de 19 après avoir inquiété de nombreux
pays ces derniers temps le variant delta
qui est maintenant en russie
il représente actuellement à 90 % des
nouvelles contaminations voyez justement
est les précisions de notre
correspondante à moscou vera d'hoffmann
17200 sur son deux nouveaux cas de
couronnes au virus ont été enregistrés
aujourd'hui la russie revient aux
chiffres du mois de février dernier les
autorités sanitaires explique la flambée
des contaminations par un mépris total
des gestes-barrières cette évaluation
est également partagée par le kremlin
une des raisons est le bas niveau de
vaccination le mépris total le bas
niveau de vaccination de plus le
caractère sournois de l'infection n'est
pas à négliger
naturellement c'est un sujet qui fait
l'objet d'un suivi permanent par le chef
de l'état il reçoit des rapports
quotidiens à la fois de la part du siège
du gouvernement et des dirigeants
régionaux
il surveille donc la situation de la
manière la plus attentive
c'est la chose la plus importante à
l'heure actuelle quant au changement
dans l'emploi du temps du président il
n'y a pour l'instant aucun changement
le président travaille activement vous
pouvez le constater il ne faut pas
oublier que tous les pays sont
confrontés à une amplitude différentes
de vagues de cette infection
une autre chose est que oui nous sommes
en retard sur le taux de vaccination par
rapport à beaucoup de pays nous sommes
en retard
nous avons peu réussi à cet égard permet
pas parce que quelque chose nous manque
nous avons tout ce dont nous avons
besoin en quantité même plus que
suffisante
tout cela était assurée toute
l'infrastructure a été mise en place
il y a quelques mois moscou épicentre de
l'épidémie en russie a également
enregistré un nouveau record aujourd'hui
plus de 9000 cas en 24 heures le maire
de la capitale sergueï sobianine a
expliqué la hausse des chiffres des
malades par la propagation du variant
delta de cours d'un virus qui serait
plus contagieux et plus dangereux la
ville selon sergueï sobianine commence à
revivre la situation du début de la
pandémie
les dernières données que nous avons
obtenus sans que 89 3 % des malades ont
contracté en coronavirus ayant muté guy
delta qui est un variant un bien
il s'est avéré plus agressif et se
propage plus rapidement et c'est ce qui
est le plus troublant pour le contrer le
statut immunitaire d'une personne ou
comme on dit aujourd'hui le nombre
d'anticorps chez une personne doit être
deux fois plus élevé que pour résister
au virus de gohan en fait nous
commençons à revivre cette histoire mais
avec des conséquences plus graves
c'est pourquoi nous constatons une telle
explosion du taux d'incidence et une
forte augmentation du nombre de cas
d'hospitalisation c'est vraiment un
accroissement énorme
nous mettons en service presque tous les
jours de nouveaux hôpitaux de nouveaux
bâtiments pour lutter contre qu'ovide et
nous arrivons à peine à suivre le rythme
des cafés des restaurants exemple du
coronavirus seront offert à moscou pour
les visites et les gens auront besoin
d'un code qr confirmant leur vaccination
le maire de moscou a ajouté que depuis
le 18 juin la participation spectacle
accueillant du public dans la ville
seraient limitées mille personnes
pourront être présents lors de tels
événements au maximum l'afrique
s'inquiète aussi de l'augmentation du
nombre de 4 go vite sur le continent et
c'est l'om est ce qui tire la sonnette
d'alarmé et le nombre de décès dus au
virus a augmenté de 15% la semaine
dernière à des hôpitaux africains qui
craignait d'être débordée de ne pas
pouvoir accueillir tous les patients qui
on aurait besoin
hélène masse cogner
20 % de cas en plus chaque semaine dans
22 pays du continent africain
une hausse qui s'explique notamment par
l'arrivée de l'hiver en afrique australe
et la propagation de variants plus
contagieux l'organisation mondiale de la
santé s'inquiète de cette augmentation
exponentielle des contaminations tandis
que plusieurs pays notamment l'ouganda
voient leurs hôpitaux débordés
nous n'aurons pas la quantité d'oxygène
nécessaire pour faire face à une arrivée
continue de patients mais qui pour le
moment nous en produisons assez pour 200
personnes mais quand le nombre de
patients augmentera encore nous n'aurons
plus assez d'oxygène pour les 900 lits
que nous avons ici mythe des piments et
n'est pas passé
pour ne pas subir un débordement des
structures sanitaires comme en inde
l'afrique devrait tester massivement la
population pour isoler les cas de kovy
19 selon l' oms l'organisation qui a
pour leur fournit 90 millions de tests
antigénique à 39 états africains
dans le même temps la campagne de
vaccination stagne avec seulement 1 % de
la population ayant reçu les doses
nécessaires
l'om est-ce demande d'une accélération
de la livraison des vaccins et une
reprise en main de la campagne de
vaccination par les différents pays
il est très clair que l'afrique est la
région africaine de l'om s envoie des
signaux forts indiquant que la maladie
est en augmentation que son impact est
croissant et que nous devons agir
rapidement pour soutenir ses systèmes et
faire vacciner les personnes les plus
vulnérables en afrique et bien fou ces
cinq derniers jours
la campagne a connu une nette
accélération à l'échelle du continent
avec 5 millions de doses administrées
mais le conte est encore loin des
objectifs mondiaux à savoir 10 % de la
population de chaque pays
vacciner d'ici à septembre pour
atteindre ce chiffre
l'afrique a besoin de 225 millions de
doses supplémentaires
selon l' oms 90% du continent risquent
de ne pas être en mesure d'atteindre ce
palier
et au kenya la situation est aussi
alarmante le pays se prépare à une
quatrième vague d'infection pour freiner
la propagation du virus des mesures de
confinement ont été prises dans l'ouest
du pays mais les hôpitaux un manque cet
oxygène et s'inquiètent d'être débordé
par le manque de moyens écoutez
justement à peter ngumbi docteur d'un
hôpital de la ville de macha causse en
ce qui concerne la préparation étant
donné que nous prévoyons une autre vague
je dirais que nous devons probablement
faire plus en terme de fourniture et de
capacités car actuellement nous
fonctionnons avec onze lits au maximum
12 dans cette installation
pour l'instant nous sommes capables de
gérer les patients que nous recevons
mais si cette vague arrive nous risquons
d'être dépassés au niveau de la capacité
en termes de fourniture
je commencerai par les produits
pharmaceutiques en ce qui concerne aux
médicaments nous avons également une
pénurie sur les médicaments de base que
nous donnons et hausse du nombre de cas
de décès en amérique latine recensés ces
derniers jours focus sur le paraguay est
fou la situation dans les hôpitaux est
toujours critique manque de matériel
respiratoire de lits personnel à bout et
une campagne vaccinale qui tourne au
ralenti en tonneau juillet et amaya
soulève la fabrication de cercueils une
activité tristement prospère au paraguay
ces artisans ne comptent plus leurs
heures pour permettre aux victimes du
coc vide de partir dignement
ces derniers jours le nombre de
contaminations et les décès connaissent
une nette augmentation avec une
population de plus de 7 millions
d'habitants
le paraguay déplore plus de onze mille
décès duo kobe 19 pour quelques 400
mille cas une situation insoutenable
pour les hôpitaux
ce qui comptera le personnel médical a
refusé des patients
nous avons même supplié qu'il s'occupe
de ma mère dans un hôpital public mais
ils ne nous ont accordé aucune attention
ils ont seulement dit qu'il n'y avait
pas de place à ce moment là parce que
c'était saturé c'est ce qu'ils nous ont
dit les patients ne sont pas directement
rejetée mais quand il arrive
nous leur expliquons qu'il n'ya plus
assez d'oxygène donc qu'ils ne peuvent
pas recevoir les soins qu'ils méritent
et oui malheureusement depuis deux
semaines des patients sont refoulés
les dirigeants du pays met en cause un
manque de doses qui ralentit la campagne
de vaccination et favorisent la
propagation du virus
ce week end dans la capitale asuncion
après des heures passées dans les files
d'attentes environ 50000 paraguayens ont
pu se faire vacciner mais avec moins de
500 milles primo vacciner les autorités
sanitaires préviennent que la situation
ne devrait pas s'améliorer de sitôt
l'ensemble du pays pratiquement 70 %
présentent un niveau très élevé de
transmission communautaire de sorte que
les prévisions sont assez sombres pour
ce mois principalement et probablement
pour une partie du mois de juillet si
l'ensemble des pays d'amérique latine
demeure fortement touché par la crise
sanitaire
ces deux dernières semaines avec un taux
de près de 25 décès pour cent mille
habitants
c'est au paraguay que le taux de
mortalité a été le plus élevé au monde
au fond ce maintenant le gouvernement
étudie la réouverture des discothèques
après plus d'un an de fermeture et
pourra à nouveau accueillir du public le
mois prochain dans des conditions
strictes s est en tout cas ce qu'a
annoncé olivier veyrier hier chez nos
confrères de bfm tv est les
professionnels attendent encore une date
et des conditions précises le ministre
de la santé s'est voulu rassurant nous
travaillons sur un protocole sanitaire
en vue d'ouvrir les discothèques cet été
en juillet les discothèques sont anna à
rouvrir avec des conditions spécifiques
et pour pratiquer malvaes président du
syndicat national des discothèques et
lieux de loisirs se passe sanitaires
imposées pour entrer en discothèque
peut-être un problème est facilité assez
soit premièrement un parcours vaccinale
complet parcours vaccinale complet il ya
30 % des jeunes qui sont contre le
vaccin
au jour d'aujourd'hui il ya un peu plus
de 6% des moins de 29 vols qui sont
vaccinées le voyez ça nous fait une
clientèle qui très réduit deuxièmement
le passe à lithaire ça peut être aussi
un test en petits génies négatif mais il
doit de moins de 48 heures un test un ti
génique négatif de -2 48 heures ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui va en discothèque
un dimanche soir pour ce faire le test
antigénique la matinée du samedi 20
journées du samedi le verser sur son
d'application tout senti coheed de façon
à faire enregistrer qui va faire ça ça
me dit comment ça va être enregistrées
va et les exploiteurs les clients qui
sont en vacances
est-ce qu'ils vont devoir se promener
avec un coton-tige tout au long des
vacances pour tous les deux jours se
refaire un test pcr
c'est absolument impossible donc c'est
un gros problème pour nous les
conditions de remise en main c'est une
décision inédite ce que vient de prendre
la justice belle hier après plus de six
ans de procédure elles le tribunal de
première instance de bruxelles a
condamné les autorités du pays pour leur
politique climatique négligence
explications en images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
à
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour nicolas van noppen président de
coalition climat cette décision doit
permettre au gouvernement de prendre de
nouvelles décisions politiques en terme
de climat alors l'argument qui est
employé par le tribunal c'est de dire
fixer les objectifs c'est pas le rôle de
la justice donc je constate que les
objectifs sont insuffisants mais par
contre je ne veux pas atteindre à la
séparation des pouvoirs dit le juge
et donc je ne veux pas être celui qui
fixe les objectifs mais donc derrière il
ya bien le constat que les objectifs
sont insuffisants et la nécessité pour
nos responsables politiques de rehausser
l'ambition ce que nous espérons c'est
que les dirigeants belges à tous les
niveaux de pouvoir entendront le message
comme ça a été le cas des dirigeants
hollandais puis des dirigeants allemands
en important maintenant c'est qu'il ya
un déclic en faveur de plus d'ambition
peu importe qui en fonction passe le
jugement est très clair et donc il faut
aujourd'hui une des décisions politiques
qui suivait notamment ce que le juge met
en évidence c'est que là où nos
politiques en belgique ont tendance à se
cacher parfois de dire la complexité
institutionnelle de notre pays
le juge dit ce n'est pas une raison
adoptée ici début juin au palais bourbon
le projet de loi relatifs à la
prévention d'actes de terrorisme et aux
renseignements est actuellement examiné
au sénat est le texte à père élise les
mesures d'exception prises après les
attentats de 2015 mais cela peut avoir
un prix qui marosi sans surprise
et contrairement à ce qui avait été
promis à l'époque l'état d'urgence de
2015 aura bien fini par s'immiscer
durablement dans le droit commun le
présent projet de loi vise à pérenniser
à compléter les instruments de
prévention de la commission d'actes de
terrorisme dont le législateur a doté
l'autorité administrative à l'issue de
l'état d'urgence est alors que le niveau
de la menace demeure toujours très élevé
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
au moins c'est assumer on peut ainsi
noter dans ce projet de loi dit relatif
à la prévention d'actes de terrorisme et
renseignements la perpétuation des mika
ou mesures individuelles de contrôle
ministre hâtif et de surveillance un
système d'assignation à résidence pour
les personnes suspectées de sympathie de
terroristes ou encore les visites
domiciliaires le nouveau nom des
perquisitions administratives qui sont
désormais soumises à l'accord de
l'autorité judiciaire
la nouvelle loi pérennise également la
possibilité d'instaurer des périmètres
de sécurité en cas d'événement à risque
où le pouvoir administratif de fermer
des lieux de culte des mesures qui n'ont
guère satisfait les observateurs du
respect des droits humains
ce texte vise à pérenniser et même à
renforcer les mesures antiterroristes
exceptionnelles dans nous demandons
l'abrogation depuis plusieurs années car
comme nous l'avons démontré à de
multiples reprises dans nos enquêtes
elle porte atteinte au droit à un procès
équitable au droit à la vie privée et
familiale ou encore au droit au travail
mais si vous avez bien retenu le nom de
cette loi vous avez compris qu'elle
comporte un autre volet relatif aux
renseignements cette fois avec le
renforcement des boîtes noires des
algorithmes de traitement automatisé des
données de communication électronique de
l'ensemble de la population transitant
sur les réseaux des opérateurs de
télécoms et des fournisseurs d'accès à
internet en clair une écoute généralisée
nos l'objectif est de détecter les
germes d'éventuelles menaces terroristes
selon l'étude d'impact de la nouvelle
loi ces algorithmes aurait généré 1739
alerte pour l'année 2020
le texte pérennise ces boîtes noires
tout en incluant désormais les url c'est
à dire les adresses des sites que nous
consultons toutes ces données de
connexion seront de plus partagés entre
services en fonction de leurs intérêts
et conserver des années durant notamment
à des fins de recherche et développement
notamment en intelligence artificielle
un futur de la surveillance française
qui là encore n'a pas fait que des
enthousiastes
les mesures de surveillance sont
disproportionnées et autorise le
placement sur surveillance de larges
portions de la population française sur
la base de motifs très large sans même
qu'un juge ait donné son accord
or aucune disposition dans le projet de
loi actuel le relatif à la prévention
d'actes de terrorisme et au
renseignement n'est prévu pour résoudre
ces problèmes
au contraire les mesures présentées
pourrait aggraver ces atteintes
le projet de loi semble pourtant avoir
fédéré les élus
puisqu'il a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale par une très large majorité de
députés y compris socialistes et ce
malgré la procédure accélérée malgré les
délais entre la présentation du texte en
conseil des ministres et le vote des
députés à peine plus d'un mois très
court au regard de l'importance et de la
complexité du sujet je rappelle que
l'étude d'impact à elle seule fait plus
de 250 pages et que le conseil d'état
tout comme la cnil se sont prononcés sur
le texte en émettant parfois certaines
réserves le vote du sénat est prévu lui
dans moins de deux semaines
et là non plus l'issue ne fait guère de
doute renforçant encore un peu plus les
prérogatives sécuritaire de l'état voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci d'avoir
suivi un prochain point sur l'actualité
dans un peu plus de trente minutes
rester avec nous sur arte france à tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu